[Music]
these plates are for switches that will
be installed in hotel rooms and they
will include sockets for three pin
British plugs the automated tooling
wraps the punched metal around a form to
give it the desired shape
this framework will also serve as an
electrical grounding plate discharging
electrical energy from the socket to
prevent shocks a worker now attaches a
molded plastic part to a grounding plate
he inserts a screw and a brass connector
and installs it in a slot in the molded
plastic he installs a series of brass
terminals at the next station a worker
assembles fuseholders contacts and
springs to the plastic structure next up
our little spring operated plastic
shutters they block the sockets when
nothing is plugged into them moving down
the assembly line a worker inserts
springs into twin rocker switches she
lowers a press to squeeze all the switch
components together
then transfers the switches to the
electrical unit
another technician snaps the cover on to
it he plugs it into a light box to test
it and the bulbs of the Box illuminate
this confirms that the switches and
sockets are fully operational a worker
now fits the steel grid play to it with
the switches and sockets protruding
through it this particular unit is also
equipped with around European plug and a
USB charging port for mobile devices at
the next station
an operator serves up brass face plates
to a press that bends the rims forming a
thin lip that will fit around the grid
plate
[Music]
a computerized welder fuses studs to the
back of the faceplates placing one at
each corner these studs will fix the
faceplate to the grid plate and provide
a screwless finish on the front when it
comes to switch and socket combinations
there's no shortage of options at this
station a worker assembles a
particularly large one with switches
charging ports and sockets it's also
designed for installation in a hotel
room he secures the charging port to the
grid plate and is ready for the
faceplate he attaches it using the
welded studs and with a folded edging it
encases the grid plate neatly